[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
noises
i don't know they're melodies i can't
welcome back to the place
our daily show that keeps you updated on
all nerdy news and all the music things
that these
japanese don't listen to second innings
great expectations predictions we know
you're waiting for the great
expectations tommy i'm gonna kill you
i'm kidding you
i'm kidding you know today is all about
thor love and thunder oh my god can you
tell that tommy wrote this script tommy
i love you today's redemption because
it's a friday is gonna be a doozy for
every hundred dollars you guys can vote
in the chat we'll do a a poll and you
get to choose who gets to arm wrestle
who
let me tell you we are all
we like all worked out preemptively for
the rest
it's a very thorough thing
who's worthy who's worthy to win
[Music]
i have to wake them up
that's a process
to warm up
it's friday the guns are resting
taking a long weekend oh but i also
firstly before i introduce our a lovely
lovely host um i want to say that this
is a spoiler-free show however there may
be spoilers and comments in the chats
you've been warned we will be doing a
spoiler-free q a at the end of the show
so ask your spoiler-free questions right
now in the chat um remember to add new
rockstars that way we can make sure we
see them in our um the way that we have
it in our database so with that being
said welcome angelica trey
hi
hello wait are you welcoming me
okay and then i was that not a good
welcome no no it was great it was
fantastic thank you no no it was good it
was fun
and erica
hey everybody what's going on internet
let me see those arms
this is a muscular show today i wore the
tight shirt today i love this shirt it's
a great shirt
can i have it you can have uh
one of them
stu baker asked who is koi he's a a
comic book talk show host entertainment
journalist and comic historian and he's
happy to be here hi very happy we all
came with our
best graphic tees and by we the three of
them i keep not getting the memo goats
oh did you jump just kidding this is
from the this is exclusive from the
event i hosted wow
yeah look at that is that flavor
it says the goat marathon greatest of
all
i love that yeah that's a pretty good
memorabilia i got forever that feels
special i wanted to take two wouldn't
let me get this dress from forever 21.
um
and i think i got it on sale for like a
dollar okay
that's a come up i guess onto the
headlines
uh the news just broke the hollywood
reporter has announced that filmmaker
julius ona will be directing captain
america number four previous credits
include cloverfield paradox and loose
lucy
yes has anyone seen loose
trailer was haunting yeah
so is captain america we're going to be
a scary movie spookiest
i mean it's a black captain america he's
gonna run into some scary stuff he's
talking about real fear talk about real
fear but i mean i'm excited there's
progress on it like for me we've been
waiting a bit since falconer soldier
ended up following falcon in the winter
soldiers at the end like that last title
card was like captain america and like
you know i mean we got we got that
transition and then we like quiet yeah
they said they announced a writer
they've had some rumors but like a
director means
they're probably filming soon because
that's kind of the last like piece the
puzzle for usually the way marvel does
announcements is like okay you got this
and then we're going to reveal the
villain it's also what 10 days per
comic-con yeah interesting they didn't
announce it at comic-con we'll see if
they announced anything and they have
too much stuff lined up for comic-con
that they're like okay let's give a
little text remember it's coming and
then september is d23 so who knows what
like if they announce this now maybe
they'll have info at d23 maybe right
yeah it's teasers and then more or less
right something
all i care about is if they do not show
the black panther two trailers
i'm gonna lose i feel like i've made a
joke here that on the show that they're
just never going to give us the black
panthers it just comes up here because
we'll all see it regardless we're still
going to see it um i wanted that for
most marvel movies because they make a
billion dollars they should try that i
know that it's like that's like a
marketing thing that's like so out there
but like don't even give us the trailer
just give us a poster we will give us
the name
give me a 15 second like title subtitle
date that's how i felt about nope at
first i was like it's just the word nope
and i can't figure out what it's about
i'm seeing that next week and i still
don't know i'm so excited yeah and i
still i love that i don't know
have you seen any of the trailers and
teasers yeah but like they don't give me
like do you know what's going on i
haven't i feel like i have a good idea
of what's gonna happen in it from
okay i remember i told you guys i'm not
a horror movie guy so maybe like there's
tropes i don't understand maybe it just
made me go nope and i'm terrified i'd be
a good old probing uh amman valani gave
an interview to hme and gave fans a
glimpse of what they can expect from the
miss marvel finale among the highlights
the finale is being directed by
i i hate that i almost like burped
during her name adil
arby and belle fulla who directed the
first two episodes so we can we can look
forward to the return to that fun
animation and edgar wright style quick
edits returning which i know john is
very excited about because he talked
about in this meeting uh she also gave a
great quote about the character
we see kamala become her own version of
what a superhero hero is she stops
trying to be
this watered-down version of an episode
one and two she was copying black widow
possesses and continues to wear that
captain marvel costume because that made
her feel more comfortable now she has
her super suit and goes into full
fighter mode she's a fully fledged
superhero and it's really empowering and
badass i think people are going to have
a lot of fun watching and their jaws are
going to drop
i'm looking forward to it i can't wait
for like fully actualized you know miss
marvel's gonna be fun
i'm waiting for that outfit to fully
develop because we have a little sash in
that one episode we've seen little
pieces happen and she got the mask
versions of it but i don't know that
hulk one though it's pretty epic too oh
really honey yeah
you guys everyone was so sad about that
dad and take yourself back to being a
teenager
like get out of my room
i just hope he's doing okay he's fine
i seem pretty hurt after watching the
boys don't talk to me about dads
[Laughter]
multiverse of madness costume designer
graham churchyard
bomb last name appeared on phase zero
and revealed that uh not only was baldr
the brave cut out of doctor strange too
he was also counted out of thor one two
and three apparently it made it uh he
made it far enough along in multiverse
madness that his costume was starting to
be made before the character was
ultimately cut
that's the breaks that that that was a
break hollywood
yeah i think that's such a hollywood
thing because i i'll say stuff like this
to my mom and she'll be like that seems
counterintuitive i'm like oh welcome to
hollywood
because each one they call you back and
you're like okay now's my time i've
earned it oh what is it called when you
get um when it's like last minute they
drop you you get the fee
uh
i'm sure you got that money but it's
still not the treasure of having a
franchise or like the you know cons the
rest your life or like the appreciation
of the fans or like you know being
relevant on twitter and the stalkers and
the
disney club yeah
yeah because i mean it's a lifestyle
change like i can't imagine going from i
can't imagine getting cast and just like
thinking about it and then being like
one more movie one more movie four times
yeah right it's never coming um
in other multiverse madness news a bunch
of concept art from the film has been
released and it appears that deadpool
was slated to cameo as dr strange and
america chavez passed through a world
covered in posters of deadpool here it
is including the deadpool 2 posters uh
featuring deadpool and cable in the
creation of adam pose shazam fury the
gods released a new oh this is a second
part i'm sorry
big cameo they're having shazam and
doctor strange and deadpool
i mean deadpool and cable it would have
made sense that would have been a really
cool thing i wonder if they didn't
though because they didn't want people
to see it as the way they're bringing in
fox yeah because like you know they
already had patrick stewart we do need
that to feel like a big moment so part
of me is is bummed we didn't get it but
pardon me also would like deadpool to
come in on his own terms i.e his movie
being that fox moment
that's true that is true i agree with
that uh i just look i just it's such a
cool like what is it i mean there's that
image is dope yeah i'm like this is so
fun and i love i love a crossover look
at it look at it look at that
look at him buildings although
but then it would have drove all of our
brains into soup and madness as being
like theorizing where is he yeah is he a
star is there a movie star is that why
he's on a billboard
what worked for me i've been happy with
having that brain explode i mean yeah
honestly that sounds kind of fun oh my
god uh that was a good jay jonah jameson
impression too oh nervously i know
pictures of them
he's a menace i'm glad i can put um
deadpool i can put uh uh uh jks yeah
jacob jk simmons on my list of things i
can do impressions of uh following r2d2
and blue the dog
original the middle one that we don't
talk about magenta
no the new oh
wait they're doing a shared steve
universe there's gonna be a multiverse
of steve's
okay blue's steven universe
okay guys monday we're doing all blue
all the time oh they have joe in it
right yeah joseph okay yeah yeah joe's
the
cousin yeah joe's the one where i was
like very little and i got confused and
i was like do you guys call stephen he's
great steve is great he's such a good
tick tock so holston he's so old he's
our mr rogers now mm-hmm
i cosplayed
and he put a little trophy
in uh the hbo show and she commented and
shared it on her story and i went nuts
that's amazing that is the only person i
care about in the world and i was like i
can die now
i left it on my instagram if you guys
want to look it's very embarrassing uh
and other dc news warner brothers
confirmed that there will be a dc movie
announcement at their comic-con panel
the panel will also showcase black adam
but may also include peaks at the flash
aquaman 2 and blue beetle
um hope it's superman i'd like a man of
steel too i i just want to see the black
adam stuff i want to see everybody on
there and talking about it because i
feel like we're there's one there's one
character and black adam we're missing
and i want to see which one it is
they're not showing it yet um
interesting
also interested in what flash is gonna
take us uh finally
surprise marvel studio animation will be
at comic-con this year their animation
panel will feature updates on x-men 97
marvel zombies what if season two which
one are you guys most excited for x-men
97 yeah
yeah yeah i'm waiting for those strings
like i'm waiting for that yeah all of
them though but but yeah i think that
one's just like the one we're all just
waiting for news okay that is true that
is true i
i got so sucked into what if yeah i got
so sucked into whatever and jeffrey
wright is the only man i love
i was like i was like i need to get i
need a second season i can't wait i just
wanted to be more canon than what it is
because we talked about this yeah and
how weirdly they like sidecannon you
can't just bring in a character for a
minute and be like oh and it's like yeah
i want her storyline from what if in
this captain i'm not that one zombie
stranger but not quite that dumb
no not quite not quite i'm like we're
gonna use ultron to make it look like
it's the wonder for the thing you love
that's the beauty of what if though is
you don't know what's going to leak its
way into
you know some of the movies and then
what's going to be completely apparently
season two is a lot phase four based
whereas like it was phase one through
three with season one so it's gonna be
more focused so i'm intrigued by like
maybe that'll tie into secret wars phase
five planting some seeds yeah okay
really quick i want to shout out
francisco that said bbc break room blues
clue
yes
yes
more acronyms to confuse us in the run
yeah yeah bbc and bbw gonna be a big
week in the break room he's gonna be
like does it say bbc that's great yeah i
sure did
he's like what did eric do while i was
gone
um oh now it is our time our moment to
shine love and thunder our free
discussion we're going to talk about it
there's not going to be any spoilers
from us per se but in the chat they
might go off a little bit we can't
monitor everybody we prefer they didn't
yeah yeah but here we go try your best
try your best
i would ask nice once they're gonna be
like nope
actually angelico
here's every spoiler
oh you know they copy paste i've been
seeing so much on youtube and stuff
people just literally like write it out
once and i kinda i was like oh i can
talk about it now and then i was like
jessica it's only been a day for them
yeah because for us it's been two weeks
and the week and a half where it was
true silence was so hard because news
kept breaking and we kept being like
yeah that's crazy that's not in there
and like it felt like a spoiler to know
what wasn't in there by a mission of us
knowing what was in there yeah so what
do you think you can further say now
about the movie that is not quite a
spoiler but more we can i think we can
go a little inch like a little droplet
more uh so broad strokes
goats uh i'm a big fan of what they were
able to do with this i think it is a
very useful
use of taika energy i think that the
goats are kind of taika at the tychist
the tychist these are the tightest goats
uh i really love the visuals because i
feel like they took what worked in
ragnarok visually and kind of kicked it
up to an 11 uh it's in the trailer so
this isn't a spoiler but there is a
black and white sequence that i am just
obsessed with i've thought about that
sequence since we got out of there what
are we laughing at that i missed
spoilers
spoilers oh okay i was like did i say
something stupid
i just saw attention uh but yeah i i
love the black and white stuff uh the
mighty thor stuff made me really happy
i'm a big fan of that run from jason
aaron and i think that the way they
brought the donut art to life was really
cool because mighty thor has a very
specific look about her and they blended
natalie portman's jane foster look with
the mighty thor look um my favorite
character in the movie i wanted more of
and i'm hoping maybe deleted scenes but
valkyrie i thought was much closer to
what i think she was meant to be in
ragnarok there's a lot of things in her
arc in ragnarok where she went from like
kind of the underdog trying to figure
out who she was again to more
self-actualized but there was a lot of
pain in that story they didn't really
get to tell because i think they were
still in a little bit of a a lot of
suits uh edit and this time they got to
tell some of those stories so i feel
like we're getting more and more
valkyrie every time and i just love
tessa thompson to see her get to play in
that character was probably my favorite
thing uh and i've talked enough
yeah navigating spoilers is hard so i
was like i was ready to be like
we should have one of those like zappy
things
my brain is just like what can i say
with that
like
um i would say that um for the the the
movie itself i disney does a great job
for merchandising
look at these goats
look at these goats i want everything to
go so everyone in the chat is going off
about the tooth nasher and tooth grinder
need all the merch yeah
yep they're from the comics and from
mythology so i think they just kept that
so the the goats whether it's the goats
in that the what do they call the
chicken pig butt in shangchi
socks in light here
yeah and like they did such a job that
i'm like i need to own everything of
this and i haven't felt like that since
i was a kid i was like oh i get it
you put wink to me it was uh
yes but there was
oh i think clearly alligator loki i mean
oh yeah i went nuts i started reading
every alligator logan comic series and
then bb-8 oh how many times
yeah bb-8 you wait to the pet avengers
because you think about it we've got
almost as many pet avengers who got
young avengers pet avengers got to be
coming maybe that's a what if
what you didn't even know you just
guys
you gotta go right
now they should hire you what if pet
avengers yeah what if
that's dressed up as batman
i also
i love the goats i did love the goats i
also remember looking over to voss while
i was watching and i was like if these
goats don't shut up
in my mind they were just scared of the
but um i would say that i guess my
favorite character was
was jane was jane i think i didn't
i like i like this jane that's like
so strong jane's always been strong but
this jane that was like i'm not even
gonna let this uh
get in my way i'm not gonna let you get
in my way i'm not gonna let anyone get
in my way i am mighty thor and
everyone's gonna address me as such and
if you don't address me as such uh dr
jane foster will do and i was like god
good good good job natalie portman um i
the natalie portman films i watch are
also like completely different than what
this is yeah so it's like this natalie
portman and this jane hit me so well
so one i loved it
yeah no she was amazing i i'm loving
what the mcu has been doing with these
extremely complex
female characters lately and i i know i
don't want to go fully into that but
just even between that and wanda and
what's been going on there it's really
great to see more intentions and
motives behind
actions and things you know like i i
do not want to go too far into this
because i don't want to accidentally
spoil anything but yeah i agree like she
was a great character so she also felt
like natalie portman does a lot of you
know you're saying the movies usually
watch with her but she felt really
invested in this for a blockbuster i've
definitely seen some blockbusters where
i'm like does she want to be here and
this one it felt like she wanted to be
here she cared about the character she
was invested and it was big right and
it's like it's i'm not to uh
on taekwond but it's like
it's it's uh it's not like portman
she can do anything um and so i'm glad
that she was like yeah i'll come back
and do the another thor movie it's been
a minute well and she's so invested in
the cancer storyline and making sure
that felt like it had some weight to it
like she she loved that uh this is a
shameless name drop i'm so sorry i i met
her at comic con that one year and we
talked about the story line and how much
she loved that they were able to make
that as important as anything else and
how the cancer storyline really affected
how she perceived how that character
could be portrayed because we all know
she didn't come back for in-game like
she was so like the fact that she read
that was like i really want to do this
justice so for years i've been wondering
how it was going to play and i thought
they did in a movie of this balance you
know great yeah and in addition to
natalie portman coming back and being in
the thor universe again like i like the
other surprise characters from old fours
that came back and popped up and said
hey what's up uh we got this one too and
i did love the cinematography like i
liked how
it wasn't as super colorful and bright
as ragnarok i feel like that might have
kind of turned me off to ragnarok
i'm the only one who didn't love riding
rotten no you're not you're the only one
i used as an example though
is my favorite one right now was cool
but i didn't love it but i liked how
this one was like
well shot and the cinematography was
really cool and then the switch to the
black and white um in like gore's world
which i would love a t-shirt of
i need a gorsworld t-shirt if anybody
wants to make me one of those that was
really cool to me and you know i paint
so it's nice to see color come in and
out and be desaturated and all that
stuff so love that uh i love the theme
of family in this thor movie uh it's
going it's gonna pull out your heart
strings uh there's a lot maybe it won't
or maybe well maybe you don't have a
family maybe you're a robot and that's
fun
if you're a robot like jessica and don't
enjoy emotions
but yeah just the theme of family just
kept coming up in this movie um and i
really enjoyed it i enjoyed what uh the
journey they took thor on because you
know they're doing a really good job of
taking thor on clear journeys right he's
trying to figure himself out he's trying
to figure out what the next thing is
what the next adventure is and it's
never like ham fisted or oversold to us
i like how they just let things develop
yeah i think that's been a really
consistent theme with thor as well as
we've just seen him changing so much
from movie to movie
and he does seem really lost you know we
definitely got that sense from
the the last movies as well as uh even
just the trailers alone and how he's
just trying to find himself and so it's
kind of cool to see some
development there yeah i'm trying to
skirt the line of
you know no spoilers but it's more so
it's just like how the characters do not
spoil it's like how the characters make
you feel and how the story make you feel
yeah and i genuinely like it it's thor
is not my favorite uh character by any
means but for some reason his movies are
my favorite
and maybe it's because they don't take
themselves so seriously that it's like
it's still campy and fun and i still am
a child at heart and a comedic person so
i need that to stay to pay attention i
have a short attention span i need that
like little humor every now and then if
it's just dialogue and anger i'm not
gonna be able to really like
focus on it yeah i'm gonna be like it
keeps you engaged what's going on and
then when explosion happens
oh the chemistry too honestly between
you know uh like uh thor and
people like guardians you know it's it's
really great to see the comedic
chemistry and so i think that definitely
keeps me engaged
the oh god you guys okay we will get
feel free feel free go ahead and still
ask us questions about the movie in the
chat because we're gonna answer them at
the end and make sure to hashtag not
hashtag to at new rockstars so we can
make sure it gets in our database i also
want to remind you guys again we will
arm wrestle if we break 100. we're
almost there so we do break this hundred
you two you guys can choose the two of
us that get to arm wrestle and i know
you want to see our biceps yeah i'm the
only one wearing long sleeves
just imagine
yeah yeah and if they are then it works
i'll just put my arm in front of your
body like this yeah
that'll be there
in person photoshop yeah
also this is how my hand works it's like
oh god i don't know how to bend my
fingers um it's a very intense
don't worry about this just
look at me i'm worried
oh we got some polls in the chat would
you rather see boulder and multiverse
madness or thor 11 thunder 60 of you
guys said thor love and thunder and i
actually very much agree
uh what dc show
case are you most excited for black adam
yeah baby
blue beat off 15 an awkward man at 12.
damn oh flash it eight damn blue beetle
makes sense the costumes look great but
a lot of people might not know about it
i don't think they know blueberries so
the fact that it's second is impressive
because because we just had some leaked
paparazzi photos and the name is not
like household aquaman and flash are
just not not doing it yeah that's okay
oh yeah oh yeah that's sure i forget
about press blue beetles costume
though way cooler than black adams
so cool i love it i don't know how they
got that luminescence to appear like in
real life because it's just stills and
it looks incredible they did they did i
will say dc i love their costumes uh
they do very well good justice for me
for their costumes and on to a little
bit of ads we're going to come back to
your guys's questions don't worry about
it um if there's one thing thor love and
thunder made crystal clear it's that the
gods have good skin oh god
they do have good skin i made that
reference because i have horrible skin
which makes sense because gods are
mythical beings and there um there
aren't a lot of myths about dry flaky
skin so if you want divine radiant glow
you got to work on your skincare routine
and that's where geology comes in
[Applause]
mine says vital morning face cream
i've got some repairing night cream oh i
need that i'll decide i've got the good
good rub-a-dub-dub-dub does it say that
no it doesn't it says everyday face wash
this one is
um and i got the nourishing eye cream
folks at geology hooked me up with some
of the skincare products that i've loved
geology is a nine-time award-winning
men's skincare company that creates
simple effective personalized
personalized skincare products for men
click the link in this video's
description it's below and take a 30
second quiz tell them about your skin
and their team of dermatologist designs
a regimen just for you that ships
directly to your door knock knock who's
there geology uh it's great for folks
worried about acne dark eye circles
wrinkles or signs of aging oh god it's
hitting me they send you a 30 day trial
set that's easy to incorporate into your
routine whether you're new to skincare
or a seasoned expert they sent me
all of these products and maybe you can
get them too and you can also get these
lovely friends
they also come with the product we carry
the products right so you're doing hello
we're the ones knocking
koi just breaks down the door
night time daytime
you're welcome
eye cream
what was that were you just squeezing
into their eyes
like aggressively you were
either way i love that they do what they
do thank you for me they send what i
need and just have and i just have to
use it they're offering a crazy deal
right now you can get 70 off on the
30-day five-piece special wow that's so
special that is a special
head to geology.com to 70 off on your
30-day trial when you use the promo code
rockstar 70 or just click the link below
that's geology.com promo code rockstar
70 to save 70 off on your 30-day trial
okay now put it back in here put it back
in here
we also have our new thor latest
obsession shirt which is amazing look at
it right there baby
the 80s motif coming back makes me so
happy that's great i love it i'm happy i
love it and i hate it not the shirt just
the 80s just the 80s i started going
back to the 70s and the 80s came right
back around and i'm still dressing in
orange we need that optimism we need the
80s was just like we believe we just
went for it i'm sticking to the 70s funk
will never die
funk will
[Laughter]
oh
nothing gets me going for the what is it
the break room blues clues bbc
you guys this is mandatory fun we are
gonna play a game that i like to play
and you know my games for mandatory fun
are ridiculous this game is a
a nice nice family game called smasher
pass hell yeah you play this at home on
thanksgiving christmas dinner you're
waiting for the the turkey to finish
roasting
you are going to play this game with
your mom and dad and grandma and grandma
oh grandma loves master pass yeah
your grandma said smash
yeah you're gonna take it ready you're
gonna raise her chicken and raise all
right
you guys i'm gonna give you guys um five
superheroes from thor love and thunder
and i wanna know if you guys are gonna
smash a pass
so i'm going to show you the image that
i have right here on my on my table and
you guys in the chat please tell me
smash your pass smash or pass baby are
you guys ready yes yes corey can you
write
are you guys sure you don't want me to
arm wrestle coins
grip strength's different than biceps 53
so for the first person we have for
smash or pass i don't don't let them see
your answers we got
korg
from thor love and thunder from thor
ragnarok how do we feel about korg are
we gonna smash or pass you guys
in the chat
smash or pass cork i'll tell you right
now
i'm a smash
because he's a sweet man and if there's
anything i learned about thor love and
thunder is he's very sweet let's go
ahead and flip our boards i messed up i
was thinking one thing and then i wrote
the other thing just like what oh my god
this is not hard
in my head
there we go okay ready yes let's see
turn him around
we got smash
pass oh i have a reason i with friction
i worry lube would hurt him i thought he
said freaking glory no no friction
but dangerous you have just because
you're like
you got soldier or not soldier boy black
noise
but no i just feel like because if you
get lube in a rock i don't know that's
gonna doodle and i feel like he's going
to make us yeah
then he's all gushy forever i just worry
for him
that's prime for smashing i just i want
you i just had i had a dangerous image
thank you
i just worried smasher pass we have 54
percent said smash y'all wild what'd you
like yeah smash of course
he's sweet but he's got that soft you
know interior he's he's very considerate
like
[Music]
he's got a good personality i'm
attracted to this person
okay i open this one easily that's nice
that feels good what are you doing smash
and pass
korg
oh smash lights yeah
nice of you too cork smash
oh i keep the powder
okay
we got one more and now one more we got
a couple more
i would be so sad smash smash smash or
snazzy pants smash smash pass we got
jane foster aka mighty thor smashing
over passing fellas smashing a passing
oh jessica in the chat immediately said
pass
damn yeah
someone was not a fan of the ending of
black swan
i love the black swan and that's why i
love her no i like her for the um
the movie with ashton kutcher who knows
when she was young when she played the
um
leon the professional or closer i guess
that was a good one too with um v for
vendetta oh classic what was the one
with james franco and danny mcbride your
highness your highness yeah the mythical
one yes almost in pineapple express
okay three two one let me see those
boards babies
we got smash we got smash and we got
smash that's three smashes 87 percent
and the chat sits back she's on my
laminated ball
passes forever i'd rather not said 100
smash selena said smash did not pass him
in the chat yeah
let me find out hi selena
what's going on in that building
i think she'll impersonate my hall pass
list since like high school like like
all like she's been on every iteration
like natalie portman's like a permanent
yeah she's her best friend for everybody
yeah
that's just yeah that's why the
laminated smash that perspective she's
not perfect because she graduated from
harvard she's like wicked smart wicked
talented smackdown wicked smack kid
she's having like a smackdown
oh yeah you're from boston oh yeah yeah
yeah like a wicked man like partying
there's that like beastie boys music
video yes for snl and the natalie
portman sequel
go ahead and start a poll with the four
of our names the two with the highest
votes are gonna arm wrestle
and while we're waiting for that poll
our next one
zeus um
there's a cancelled
graphics which honestly for your side of
the table should always be playing
we are the offensive
you're gonna smash or pass
for zeus
titan of kings
light yep
let me see everybody's things we got a
pass we got a pass we got a you guys
don't like russell i just don't know
where he's been he's been a lot of zeus
has been everywhere yeah i know zeus is
history yeah is this gets around yeah i
just don't i don't trust bad vibes
is this a red flag is like a red flag
yeah i think
i think it might be a red flag ask that
on a first date and you'll probably know
you get a good feeling
right looks like i'm a walking red flag
i think the self-appointed is walking
red flag
i like i like someone that likes a lot
of people
i like someone uh who do we get in the
poll who's who's doing it it's koi verse
god damn it
it's because you took the marker off
right here
[Music]
okay that's good to know
do you want to do the hand thing where
you hold it and then let's go sure
god
stop saying it's happening let me just
go ahead and brought a tank to the gun
shelf
all right
i'm not ready
wait there's not even a table on my side
okay on my account
ready
set go
[Laughter]
go go go go
go hard
we
[Applause]
i have money
she almost had me there she was totally
worthy she got this oh my god that hurt
i'm sweating
so we all agreed we're smashing zeus
okay
that was hard
didn't even break a sweat this is how uh
unathletic
thor
thor himself
god of thunder hmm
ooh storm you're right just got the
vapors right now
sweating like a center in a church
so specific
this is what my mom was saying
like a center in a church i was like
you're right damn that was hard left
hand maybe right hand i was drinking
maybe right now yeah that's probably
what happened yep okay you guys ready
yes let me see three two one i'm getting
a lot of smashes in the chat yeah
very barely i'd smash
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh no
i feel like he would be kind of hard to
talk to sometimes like he because he's
so naive that i'd probably get a little
frustrated i do think he's uh too busy
in the way that uh i think we talked
about this on the break room where if
it's carol danvers she's saving the
universe she's doing everything yeah i
will make sure when she comes home i
have cookie like cooked waiting for her
ready for her him though i feel like
he'd be gone so much and not even
thinking about it see i give him the
thunder but not the love
that's why but then there's that little
so the question marks about later yeah
yeah okay mr brownstone in the chat said
i only smashed with the strongest
avenger which i agree with uh that's why
hulk is my number one okay so now we got
gore the god butcher specifically this
photo makes him look like uncle fest
i mean uncle fester definite definite
smash but i'm going to see oh yeah
he's got money
that bald head
okay sure yeah
i like bald heads just not the ones that
are like decaying on this that's true
that's a good point
oh azalea rivera says smash no talking
i like that do rock paper scissors see
who's worthy we will absolutely do that
next i'm getting too many mixed smashes
and passes in the chat i think you guys
uh
what's going on y'all y'all need
jesus
you all need jesus okay let's see what
we have here
sorry man
oh
with the hearts no question mark you'll
notice that yeah
i raised that
with this oh
is that comic accurate
oh god
see i'd smash that just out of curiosity
yeah that that grip he's got yeah
so the curiosity wasn't here
i feel like i know enough though this
freaking like i know enough
yeah but you don't know like you know
tools and apparatus are going on there
and animal hooves you know that's
different that's definitely just got
demon feet actually his toes are
underneath his foot and who knows what
he can do with those tendrils
that's true i'm just saying he's got a
different matter look at that body yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that is a bunch of past you guys real
quick on the count of three we all yell
it one two three smash
i like a new experience yeah i feel like
i learned something or something
thank you you guys for smashing pass
thank you guys for getting us over the
hill with the super chats uh i will
never arm wrestle koi ever again in my
life
just because left-handed you're just i
guess
i'm humble enough to take this l but it
hurts
iterates they're there
it's a sad lowercase
l it's a lowercase l yeah it's a sad one
you guys in the chat we have um we have
someone avril saying jess please do the
goat scream from thor i don't think i am
can you turn down my mic
disrespectful
i'm just backing away so i'm not on your
guys okay nice nice
[Applause]
that's great i think this is
no matter what my stream sounds like
r2d2 so i'm trying
i'll practice my screams in the mirror
when i get it that's good that was a
solid go screaming
like your screams have an accent of r2d2
like actually falling into an r2 i
tripped the other day
everyone was like
r2d2 and i was like this is my normal
screen
um alex c says you know what else has
goats severance damn it please cover
season two we have always everyone here
loves severance i'm the only one that
hasn't watched it yet has have you guys
watched that never seen it you haven't
seen everything show yeah loved it
[Laughter]
here for the cookie says
gore's world x wayne's world crossover
shirt
could you do that could you make that i
love that you do uh am i you guys see
how i write my art is only yeah come on
it's not i'm not the guy i'm not the guy
yeah yeah i'm a talker not a drawer okay
hey you're gonna add your knowledge we
should do pictionary next
how can i immediately win this she's
like let me draw something yeah
okay
this is going to draw in a house
just too long i see mule near do you
know
jackal a jackal
the first time
film juice we did the non-dominant arms
only thank you uh you caprita said i
love the movie koi is a comic book bible
love y'all when is the nerd bae gonna
make a cameo that was nerd bang
like
nerd baby mt when um empty we we should
do a cameo really quick but he it's when
we're doing live shows i don't know if
anyone this is inside knowledge for you
guys when we're doing shows whether it's
like rogue theory or anything online
that's not in person there's always a
lag and i'm usually the one
making the leg so it takes like 10
minutes for them to respond to any of my
comments
uh so it gets kind of hard to you know
internet
spectrum
fray girl says totally team goats i'm
convinced socks is al flerkin when am i
going what am i going to like the most
in thor love and thunder
so she's saying ai flirkin which is the
cat from captain marvel artificial
intelligence i got you uh i love that
headcanon i live for that uh what is so
frey girl is a comic book zealot like
myself and i'm trying not to give
anything away because not spoilers but
you're going to love
that it has the sensibility of walt
simonsen's thor in some moments and
jason aaron's thor's and other moments
while maintaining a sense of taika
reality and mixing in some of the
ultimate commentary that mark miller
infused with a bit of the self-awareness
that we're experiencing in phase four
beauty [ __ ] b.o.t
chris contu says new rockstar's favorite
scene without context oh i love spoilers
oh that's fun um
i'm gonna say uh
glass shattering
hmm
okay
the reason for the title
that was sweet yeah
hmm
messing with thor's nose
tickling his
[Laughter]
yeah
what about the scene when i uh kiss
valkyrie and then we go oh that was hot
yeah yeah i love that
congratulations
[Laughter]
did you feel like some of the verbiage
and thor felt like it was a parody
hmm
i mean it's a tyka comedy like i i i
feel like we can let's
talk about it via ragnarok it's you know
i mean
phillip said it the best way that uh uh
thor ragnarok this is like the ragnar
just like more emotional and it's true
for me i'm like it still gets the
silliness and stuff but i am much more
emotionally tied to this one than thor
ragnarok yeah i i think that ragnarok
felt a lot more outwards whereas this
one feels a lot more inwards does that
make sense i don't think that's no i
think i think i understand what yeah
yeah cause it's very internal i think
and that's why i think i like thor
ragnarok because i can watch it this is
so cool um but then um when i watched
thor love and thunder i was like this is
real yeah like i understand this yeah jd
meyer says why do you think love and
thunder is scoring low on rotten
tomatoes at the moment i think it's uh
realistically probably and i don't know
if the spoiler uh only i don't
understand how pacing works in films i
guess because some people are like oh it
goes too fast um oracle's too slow and
i'm like eh but i also don't think that
superhero movies get that big of radians
anyways because most of the critics are
like people that would rather watch uh
citizen kane on the loop or scorsese
film we know you are you are fanboys and
big girls those are those marty heads
yeah
i got a slightly different take and i
think it's that um the mcu
phase four has felt intentionally
different than any other phase and i
think that there's a a thing that people
expect from marvel that they're not
getting and i think that eternals had
the same you know kind of struggle so i
loved eternals but i think i'm seeing
something they might be doing in five or
ten years that isn't necessarily if
you're not exposed to comics an option
so i think it's just expectation versus
delivery and maybe people expecting a
certain thing and then that's not
exactly fair to the film like if you
expect something and don't get it you
didn't make the movie so i think the
critics might want something that
they're not getting and they're getting
like upset at the thing that delivers
yeah don't uh listen to the coin don't
do that because that's why star wars
starts changing a lot of their stuff and
i love it and i don't want them to
change anything i wanted kenobi to be a
movie so bad and when i heard they
didn't make an ob movie because they
were like well the fans weren't like
solo and i was like no
i liked it so someone did the same thing
to like just be like nah you know it
would have been a great movie it would
have been a great movie
it will be you guys you can still get a
movie no we can't yeah but you get more
time with the show that's true
yeah but it was like it was so perfectly
like all of that could have been just
easily put into one long good one yeah
and then they were gonna make it a
trilogy so i was like oh baby
they did
either way
it's another it's a hill that i will die
on uh band's world that does the buns
world
in one word was there any sign of
incursions in this movie
um
no
not really
no
i don't even think we can tell you
honestly i don't think we can tell you
but they also taikawa tt in an interview
said this has nothing to do with the
multiverse oh okay he said in his own
interview he was like this we don't
we're not talking about that in my movie
yeah so yeah that's the one there yeah
that's the only reason why i said no
working on a new show for nerd stuff is
really nice because i know everything
that we've already talked about um
fernando says is it just me or is anyone
else ready for these stories and the
phases start coming together
oh yeah yes
don't you think they already are yeah i
mean we're getting some overlap and some
interweaving stuff i i feel like at this
point anything's kind of possible you
know we're starting to see things cross
you know i'd expect some announcements
that'll make people feel better soon so
oh okay comic-con yeah yeah there you go
i'd expect some things to make i mean
and i don't this isn't coming from any
inside information like honestly i think
it's a matter of this has been
intentionally disparate like the comic
books are if you read marvel comics
you're gonna have like 50 issues that
don't connect and then there's an event
that brings them all together but then
you go back through that event you see
all the seeds planted every comic
doesn't feel like it's one unique thing
it doesn't feel like one universe all
the time it feels like like talking to
your grandma in the other side of the
country you're not gonna have the same
stories you're not gonna have the same
experiences and then when you go to
family reunions you're like oh i did
experience something akin to that i
think that's how comics feel and i think
there's going to be something that makes
this all feel like one i don't know what
it is i got some theories but i think
we're going to get this but it has to
you the question is all of them i think
not just a few uh well i don't know
about all of them but i mean the second
i i heard that you know kevin feige
went on this like long retreat to plan
out seven years right of of mcu you know
next what's happening next i was like
okay there is a grand scheme in all of
this i'm not worried at all all going to
yeah all of these crossroads are going
to a line yeah but even if it doesn't
like you know let's enjoy the ride
because these are fun bright colorful
movies that are mostly primarily for the
children and the next generation growing
up so you know whether they connect or
not which they probably are connecting
these have been fun rides at the
chongxie was great you know one
division's been great
thor 11 thunder fantastic
ride the wave yeah let's go back and
watch cory in the house
stu baker says if thor could share his
powers
uh oh i don't know
i'm not going to read that okay
i love your comments but it feels too
much like a little bit of a spoiler for
me um
do you guys think we get enough
christian bale absolutely i think
there's no yeah they talk christian bale
talked about how they cut
some of the scenes and also he surprised
that they left a lot of scenes in and
clearly i i love him i love him in this
i love scary things and it felt very
scary yeah he got to he had to flex the
actor muscle yeah he did a good job he's
he's got such a good actor he's so good
i was just sitting there watching his
face the whole time like how are you ah
like i just believe every second and
every little unhinged moment you know
yeah i love it um oh and it's gone i
just want to go through the smash or
pass chat really quick so pass on zeus
83 percent y'all are monsters
thor 83 pass on gore even gore pass on
oh and then you pass out oh they passed
on common core i universally accepted
comic gore y'all y'all don't know sexy
you know what sex sells and it's comic
and jane's the winner with eighty-five
percent so you can smash on jaina
i can't believe comic gore you guys
passed on uh but i think that's also
showing a lot about myself uh i read my
fan fiction on this show once oh yeah oh
we all wait someone someone there's a
fan what do you mean we wrote we had for
mandatory fun once we had to write our
fan fictions and whitney wrote hers
about dominic torreiro and groot
oh my god
i wrote mine about the third sister and
darth vader making love tommy wrote his
about nebula and abomination
and then brandon wrote his about oh my
god what was brandon's do you remember
what brandon's was
gosh i can't remember what brandon's was
either a brand oh it was vision
it was a vision and um not baron zemo it
was zola
zola huh um
no zero no bizzola our name zola oh
he was looking through the macbook
camera at vision changing envision
didn't want to stop
american pie meets ncu you can find uh
we still need the finale to jessica's
fanfic it is on tumblr you guys i wrote
a full like page worth of the riva riva
and darth vader
it's
so good
so good i can't believe i wrote
something so great all my years of
reading fan fiction you guys that was
friday's the break room uh thanks for
asking all these questions thanks for
letting us place master pass thanks for
making me arm wrestle and lose
it was just the nominal points okay it's
okay
uh follow me on tick tock i'm trying to
grow that tick tock i give a lot of the
same insights i give here but a lot
speedier and i give you comic
recommendations every single week i read
about 70 comics a week so i give my top
few every single week i give movie
reviews give a lot of insight into the
world of comics and film and i have
youtube but i don't use it as much so
tic tac twitter instagram and socials
oh genre
c-o-y-j-a-n-d-r-e-a-u it looks like a
star wars name
c-o-y-j-a-n-d-r-e-a-u i like that you're
like you have to find me hunt me down
maybe that's why i don't have enough
followers because i'm not telling people
how to find me yeah just chase just
chase
yeah
what about you baby uh i'm here i i you
know i'm in l.a doing my comedy thing
but you can find me online on twitter uh
owusu kid uh and yeah follow me for all
my things he does stand up and he's very
good at it no i'm very supportive we're
also hanging out tonight yes
i'm excited we're getting i hop i'm
gonna get the minion pancakes
oh i heard about those are they yellow
they're okay their pancakes was banana
pudding and banana in it and the
frosting is whipped cream with uh blue
and yellow sprinkles last time i hope i
asked for it they said we're out of the
banana pudding oh so they're just
getting the pancakes with the sprinkles
and whipped cream that ain't right
that's not mine
onions babies it would have gotten a
discount right she did but it was only
10.
oh my
hello okay so i'm angelica trey you can
find me on most platforms at a tray a y
y t a t-r-a-e or angelica trey i
actually just yesterday posted up a
hella cosplay from ragnarok and was that
yesterday or the day before it was just
okay it was yesterday um and yeah i'm
always just you know posting and
streaming over on twitch if you want to
come through and hang out i'll probably
be streaming later you can come talk
nerdy with me
i have nothing oh you guys can catch me
here i'm gonna do my first final
breakdown they finally gave me a little
little room to move here in the blue
dungeon i get my first breakdown which
is me recapping all of season three of
the boys and what's next in the
franchise and i might have some secrets
that i stole from my friend who wrote
the finale so make sure to tune in it'll
be a quick breakdown by yours truly
umbrella academy will come soon one day
you guys we gotta take what we have
all night in a month we'll get to it
you could have watched one a day like
casually and then i was like and i read
all the comics and tommy and the media
was like okay now you just did this to
yourself that's just overly ambitious
you're going to do that after comic con
what are you going to do worth it bye
you guys
later